any tips for learning middlegame
principles study the games of strong
players one exercise I did when I was
younger is basically called Gaston move
you take any middle game position from
some high level game and then you try
and guess what the player did it helps
if you take positions from like a book
where there's annotations or even like a
video lecture where there's explanations
for every move
ok plane grieve Feeny master let's play
I'll play d5 I'll stick with my my usual
repertoire Bishop g5 of he'll play f6
this is a little bit ugly like the
combination of f6 and h6 but the idea is
not 5 I just want to win the bishop hair
trying to remember I studied this
recently I don't see 5 at some point but
also h5 I think is logical at some point
as well come play h5 here I do to play
h4 play h4 immediately as Bishop h5 King
D 7 Bishop g4 King c6
it's so interesting I might end up
developing my king there's a h5 King d7
look at this I'm developing my king but
I might be winning a piece Connect four
let's go Bishop g4 Oh II for a good move
opponent I feel like opponents just
booked up but I'm winning upon amis all
opponents so booked up that I'm
stumbling into weird lines I take this
or opponents just bluffing and has no
idea what he's doing
[Music]
hmm I think I can take this
so I wanted to offend my night I can't
play this because takes and my Queens in
trouble I'm thinking king g6
King D 693 King e5 that seems so wrong
but I mean king power King g6 King D 6
my c3 King e5 I don't see how white
really attacks me
it looks so wrong though as Queen e2 but
then all Queen e2 could be devastating
I have to to think here I could play
Keaney Yates maybe Keaney it's the way
to go and then just sack on each five oh
no I can't sack on each five we're gonna
char ah I don't want to draw King d6
Knight c3 what to do
I really don't want to draw King D 693 m
some imagine Queen e2 happens in the end
se3 as possible three go back
now it's so weird oh I have I have East
six actually takes takes me six might
actually be playable at first I thought
it would lose a queen but then I have
this move they should be four yeah okay
it's interesting now this move
whoa it's bits I know I know I spent a
lot of time there but I'm I'm up upon my
kings on e5 I'll play this move just
initiate some trades 1996 was actually
very nice square because I defend you
for I control c4 and I prepare f5 as
well and I I initiate trade of bishops
if I wants it when it has more time than
we started with
I have 22 seconds the position overall
should actually be reasonable I have
three ones not three all points about to
meet me what no upon's meeting me oh no
I have no other legal move that's so
dirty that's so dirty I probably
shouldn't have developed my king
that was so dirty
whoa I thought the king was good in
endgame
man I was so happy with 96 too but it's
just forced me it's been made in three I
was so oblivious apparently I played
perfectly until King D 6
I'd never played gg6 oh no I remember
looking at this line because there's a
line where the King does develop to c6
and it's playable but now it seemed like
the poet was just prepared my opponent
splits doubt defy I mean this had to be
preparation while the move and there
were so many things I wanted to do like
I wanted to play King d6 here though the
problem with King d6 was Knight c3 and
then Keaney 5 and then Queen e2 it
wasn't gonna end well I was such an
interesting game though I lost in 21
moves I might put that on YouTube that's
interesting YouTube people are gonna
tear me apart for developing my kings so
early I think it was justified though
there has to be a way for a block to be
like better here I'll imagine I don't
have access to engine I don't know how
to activate the engineer but yeah people
can tell me maybe in the chat or in
YouTube comments what I was supposed to
do anyway
YouTube people thanks for watching you
can leave an F in the chat or in the
comments and I'll see you in the future